-Thank you for being here.
This is your first time
on our show.
-I know, finally.
[ Laughter ]
-You do a very funny thing.
I was going to say you did.
You do a very funny thing.
You keep buying swag of your
husband when he was Pacey.
[ Laughter ]
You buy shirts and wear them
around the house.
And I love that you do it,
but you also wear
his jersey, too,
from "Mighty Ducks."
[ Laughter ]
Now, does he laugh at it
or does he like,
"What are you doing?"
-Well, the funny thing is
that first picture
that you just showed,
that was the first time
that he ever saw
what I had done.
So I bought this shirt.
I just love going on Amazon
and finding things that might
possibly embarrass him,
but also that he secretly loves.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the first time.
So like if you see his face,
like look at his little face,
he's so embarrassed,
but he's also loving it so much.
[ Laughter ]
-He does.
He is doing both.
He's embarrassed,
but also like, "This is cool."
-Yeah, I just come downstairs
with it on
and then he's like, "Are you --
Is that...?"
And I'm like, "Yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah."
-I also heard that you
take his swag.
When he was on our show,
we gave a mug and a T-shirt.
-The whole thing is I always
steal my husband's swag,
but the thing is, Jimmy, is now
I have all that stuff
that you gave him.
-You need more.
-So, now that I'm here,
I just need you to really bring
the level up for me.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Do you know what I mean?
I mean, Oprah gives out cars,
so is there a --
[ Cheering and applause ]
What's under my chair?
-Well, I don't know. Uh --
-Jimmy, Jimmy, this is --
-This is a mask.
[ Laughter ]
-No, Jimmy.
-Unused. [ Awkward laugh ]
-Jimmy, that's not good enough.
Come on.
-How about this?
How about --
-No, I have that bag.
-"Tonight Show" tote bag.
[ Audience oohs ]
-I have that.
-You have that?
-You gave that to Josh,
okay? Come on.
-Oh.
Oh, I have something
that I did not give to Josh.
[ Audience ohs ]
How about a Fallon sweatshirt?
You can rock this --
-Getting warmer, getting warmer,
[ Laughter ]
but I feel like it needs --
I'm talking
about sparkly, shiny.
Look, Oprah gives out
really good gifts.
-Yeah, but Oprah's not
on TV that much anymore.
[ Laughter ]
She does specials.
-Jimmy, Jimmy --
Oh!
That's actually terrifying.
[ Laughter ]
But my daughter might enjoy it.
That's something.
-Okay. Mm.
[ Laughter ]
I accept.
Thank you so much!
-Act, act like you
love it, please.
-Thank you
[ Whispering ] so much.
[ Laughter ]
-Congrats on "Anne Boleyn."
-[ Clap ] Thank you.
-You're getting great reviews.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I mean, this is a big deal.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-It's on AMC+.
Is this intimidating,
to take on a real person?
-I was so like ready to tell
a story about mothering
-Really?
-and so I got really excited
about kind of this idea
of this woman who really,
I mean, it's a mother's story.
She was trying to [bleep]
survive in her time
with the best
abilities that she could,
that women were allowed to
and, you know,
make women have a seat
at the table.
And, really, I mean,
she was a [bleep] disrupter.
[ Laughter ]
That's what's so amazing
about her
and I was just like,
"Yes! I get it.
I'm an outsider.
I'm a disrupter.
Like yeah!"
-You can't say the f-word
on our show.
-Oh!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
Dude, they're on television.
-I'm sorry.
That was not zen of me.
[ Laughter ]
-But you know what?
It was badass
and I kind of love that --
-I'm a mother.
I don't use those words.
I'm a mother.
-That's exactly right, yes.
[ Laughter ]
I think you're allowed to do
whatever you want on my show.
That's the deal.
I just love having you on here.
That's all I want to say.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Thank you for having me.
-Here's Jodie Turner-Smith
in "Anne Boleyn."
Take a look at this.
[ Laughs ]
-[ Grunts ]
-Is everything alright?
-Perfectly fine.
Stop fussing.
-Shall I come
to your chambers later?
-And what would be the point?
Until our boy is born,
you have but one job.
Concentrate on that,
if you're so concerned
with being a good wife.
[ Grunts ]
[ Grunting ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Jodie Turner-Smith, everybody.
The series premiere
of "Anne Boleyn"
is streaming now on AMC+.
New episodes come out
every Thursday.